monsieur le ministre est-ce que cette
fois vous l'avez entendu la riposte
populaire cette mobilisation de millions
de Françaises et de français partout
dans le pays qui vous ont dit que de
cette réforme en voulait pas et mes amis
de DLR faites très attention parce que
parmi les manifestants il y a sûrement
une partie de votre électorat il n'en
veulent pas parce qu'elle est injuste à
travers le report de l'âge de départ à
64 ans vous faites supporter la totalité
des efforts sur les seuls travailleurs
les classes moyennes les plus
vulnérables ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt qui ont exercé des
métiers difficiles ceux qui ont du mal à
se maintenir en emploi après 58 ans les
femmes les personnes précaires au
chômage en maladie au RSA alors
qu'aucune aucune contribution n'est
demandée aux employeurs aux revenus aux
actionnaires non monsieur le ministre
votre réforme n'est pas de gauche elle
va à l'encontre de nos valeurs de notre
récit collective souvenez-vous
souvenez-vous de ça vous avez présenté
un bilan comptable alors que nous ici
nous vous parlons d'un projet de société
et jusqu'ici au ont été des dialogues de
sourds sauf que depuis aujourd'hui les
rapports de force sont claire la colère
des Français vous oblige elle vous
oblige à prendre une ultime décision
soit vous renoncez à fracturer le pays à
mettre les Français dans la rue vous
retirez votre réforme ouvrez des
négociations collectives avec les
partenaires sociaux soit vous vous
obstinez à vouloir passer en force et je
crains qu'à ce moment là vous devriez
avoir au pire désormais le président de
la République ne peut plus se défiler il
faut qu'il parle aux Français qui ne les
poussent plus à bout qu'il les respecte
et qu'en frein enfin vous et lui vous
preniez acte du rejet de cette réforme
[Musique]